let's bring you some breaking news now
in Israel's military says it's shot dead
a person it describes as a potential
suicide bomber Israel says the victim
had possible links to Hezbollah and had
crossed into the country from Lebanon
the incident happened on Monday but it's
uh only now being made public let's
bring in our correspondent Imran Khan
who's joining us on the phone from
occupied East Jerusalem what does the
Israeli Army saying so far about the
incident Imran
where you've summarized most of it uh
what they've done is they've issued a
statement saying at the beginning of the
week an explosive device was set off
near the megiddo junction from which a
an Israeli citizen was seriously injured
the security forces work to locate the
suspects and it was during searches and
roadblocks that vehicle was stopped in
the area of mosheviada now during the
arrest of that vehicle
um the what they call an armed terrorist
opposed as Angel to Shin Bet and the
Israeli Army and who neutralized and
that's their language and killed him
they found weapons and ready to use
explosive belt and other items now this
is an incredibly serious incident we
rarely see people crossing from uh
Lebanon into Northern Israel if that's
indeed what happened they stood an
investigation uh going on
um and this was so serious uh the the
Prime Minister who was actually on a
visit to Berlin uh due back on Friday he
left today is actually coming back
tomorrow it's likely that he's going to
talk about this at some point tomorrow
the eye Israeli Army a squarely blaming
a uh has well Israeli political uh
forces are actually blaming Hezbollah
but the Army is being slightly more
careful they're saying that there's a
broad investigation where we're looking
into Hezbollah uh the Lebanese group and
now there's been no comment from
Hezbollah themselves
but this is now likely to ratchet up the
tensions within North of Israel it
really depends on how Israel reacts uh
it's going to be it's a very serious
security breach for them questions are
going to be asked as to how this man was
able to cross how he was able to come
over whether he had any help and also
the fact that they actually suppress the
news it happened on Monday we're only
just finding about it now finding out
about it now shows you that how
seriously they were taking it
um and it's likely that because the man
was still uh in Northern Israel that he
didn't want uh the news to break or so
we're investigating so it's a very
serious incident uh for Israel but we
have had no comment from Hezbollah it's
likely that they won't comment on it all
but already people are now talking here
within political circles on social media
uh that and what type of Israelis
response may well come Imran thank you
very much for that that is Imran Khan
staying across that breaking news story
for us uh in occupied Eastern Jerusalem
thank you